it was the year 2000 and seven-year-old
zenyat chao was like a lot of children
her age bright but ignored she had a
youthful enthusiasm for knowledge and
learning and with the right
encouragement it was obvious she'd go on
to do great things
but her parents were both working two
jobs apiece to make ends meet so outside
of school hours little zenya spent a lot
of her time alone she learned to cook
and clean for herself since it would
often be way past her bedtime when her
parents finally got home from work they
communicated largely through sticky
notes left for her on the fridge before
they left for work in the morning it
would be easy for someone like zenya to
fall through the cracks her potential
wasted and get forced into the same
endless rat race as her parents and that
probably would have happened if her
brush with
scp-5094 hadn't changed the course of
her life forever like a lot of parents
who couldn't spend as much time with
their children as they'd like mr and mrs
chao gave zenya occasional gifts as a
way to try and make up for their absence
mostly they gave zenya new books to add
to her growing collection but their
two-bedroom apartment only had so much
space for books a year ago the family
had bought a new desktop computer to
share these days this would be the
answer to a lonely bookworm's prayers
but the internet was still in its
infancy back then everything changed
when her parents bought her a copy of
the miss jay's whiz kid schoolhouse
cd-rom miss jay's whiz kids schoolhouse
was never a popular program produced by
shoot the moon software in 1999 the game
sold poorly on the cd-rom market for
five years until the company filed for
bankruptcy in 2004 but that didn't
matter to zenya as far as she was
concerned receiving a copy of miss jay's
wizkid school house was nothing short of
a miracle and she was far more right
than she knew she didn't have just any
piece of primitive educational software
on her hands xenya chao was playing with
magic after the software loaded a
cheerful figure appeared on zenya's
monitor this was miss jay a stylized 2d
teacher in a low res but colorful 3d
classroom what can you learn from miss
jay well pretty much anything and zenya
as a lonely kid without many friends had
all the time in the world she spent days
on end learning from miss j and soon
zenya went from a bright child to a bona
fide child genius her largely absent
parents barely even noticed when their
child started demonstrating an advanced
knowledge of mechanical engineering and
a new found fluency in swahili and not
only did miss jay now known to zenya as
miss joyce teaches students with
supernatural effectiveness she also
seemed almost like she was alive she was
a warm calm encouraging figure who took
a genuine personal enthusiasm in the
education and happiness of her students
more than many real teachers even but
sadly not all good things last forever
when zenya turned 12 her family bought a
new computer and the old miss jay's whiz
kid schoolhouse cd-rom was no longer
compatible with the new operating system
the disc gathered dust in the closet
while zenya passed through high school
and then got into a prestigious college
she received her phd several years
earlier than expected and showed such
promise in her scientific field that a
certain organization took notice you
guessed it the scp foundation the
foundation is only interested in adding
the best and brightest to their ranks
and thanks to the tutoring from miss j
zenya chaos certainly fit the bill she
was assigned to the role of junior
researcher and little did she know she
was about to run into an old friend in
her new line of work the foundation
first discovered evidence of miss jay's
anomalous qualities while researching a
series of strange forum posts in 2012
on a thread discussing abandonware which
is software for which official support
is no longer available there were
multiple reports of a so-called living
character in an old cd-rom many of them
had owned as children seeing as the
technology to use the cd-rom was
obsolete shoot the moons had reportedly
extremely low sales for the title and
nobody on the forum had kept their copy
the foundation classified this apparent
anomaly as neutralized no problem that
was until then junior researcher zenya
chao was briefed on this particular scp
10 years later she remembered exactly
what the forum posters were talking
about and what's more she still had her
old copy at home the senior foundation
researchers were astounded an
opportunity to study this forgotten
anomaly had just fallen into their laps
and it was all thanks to their brilliant
new junior researcher zenya superiors
ordered her to bring in her copy of the
miss jay's wizkid schoolhouse cd-rom and
then
real testing began and after rigorous
examination of the software it appears
by all accounts that miss jay really is
the world's greatest teacher in spite of
the fact she's a collection of pixels on
a basic cd-rom program from the tail end
of the 90s what miss j seemed to
specialize in was intensive courses she
had the ability to make students
certifiable experts in almost any
subject through courses that can last
upwards of 30 hours and spread out over
just a few days but this isn't as
students become so enraptured and
learning that they forget accounting for
their most basic needs and experience a
decline in process story miss jay's
lesson plans account for regular
bathroom meal and even recreation breaks
for students her talents easily account
for zhenya chao's remarkable academic
success the same success that got her
picked up by the scp foundation
naturally if they had a technology on
their hands that could reliably create
experts and geniuses with seemingly no
negative consequences the foundation
knew that miss j and what she had to
teach could be immensely valuable in
their mission to effectively secure
contain and protect other anomalies
but we're not talking about the chaos
insurgency here the foundation would
never start to use an anomaly for their
own benefit without proper testing so
that's exactly what they did their
experiments on
began at site 15 and after ascertaining
that miss j posed no real threat to her
students they recruited a local
elementary school to provide human test
subjects closer to miss jay's intended
demographic the foundation found that
there were a few constraints between
every lesson given by ms j to one of her
students before teaching the really
mind-blowingly complex stuff she would
always begin with a basic primer on
letters colors and numbers to make sure
she and her students were all on the
same page another constant was that all
her students would refer to her as some
variation of miss jay with examples
including the names miss julie miss
jenny and miss joy one experiment was
performed on amy myers a little girl
from the third grade her academic
records showed she was a bright and
eager student but she was described by
her teachers as being especially shy amy
referred to miss jay as miss janey and
asked to be given a lesson on her
favorite animal cats of course miss jay
gladly obliged and gave amy a 15-hour
lesson split over the course of two days
which the foundation closely observed by
the time the lesson was completed the
results were truly astonishing amy
demonstrated knowledge of feline
behavior diet and physiology on the
level of professional animal behavioral
scientists she became upset when the
session ended and the program was
switched off having become attached to
miss jay no further anomalous effects
were reported the next subject was a
student from the second grade named
devon williams devon had a poor academic
record and behavioral issues stemming
from several learning disabilities in
the past teachers had reported devon
having real difficulty engaging with
their lessons and the foundation wanted
to see if miss jay's supernatural
teaching abilities fared any better
devon chose to be educated on the
subject of trains and was given a 15
hour course on the subject's spread over
two days devon had no difficulty
engaging with these lessons and after
their conclusion he displayed a level of
knowledge on railway engineering
comparable to a graduate level education
on the subject devon was so engaged in
his lessons that he had to be physically
removed from the room once the course
had completed because he'd become so
attached to his new teacher the
foundation was feeling extremely
optimistic about the prospect of using
miss j to train potential recruits
seeming as she seemed to be able to
teach even the most difficult juvenile
subjects however the foundation needed
to prove that miss j could be just as
effective teaching adults for the next
test they recruited d14417
a 24 year old member of d-class
personnel who described himself as a
poor student and tested poorly on
pre-screening attentiveness and focus
evaluations he was the perfect candidate
for the first adult test of miss jay to
the delight of the foundation higher-ups
d-14417-excel
miss j made him a verifiable expert in
law and he was able to pass a mock bar
exam with a grade of 310 after his
course much like the children he felt
intense sadness once the experiment
ended stating that miss jay was the best
teacher he had ever had he's since been
selectively anesthetized released and is
pursuing a degree in criminal law with
his new knowledge needless to say the
foundation was impressed
the last thing they needed to know was
who exactly this miss j truly was to do
this they'd conduct an interview and
thankfully they already had someone who
had a pre-established rapport with the
subject zenya chow when zenya began the
interview miss j recognized her
immediately she was delighted to see one
of her students go on to find such
success in her chosen field zenya
questioned miss j on what she truly was
and miss jay responded that she honestly
wasn't sure all she knew for sure was
that she was passionate about helping
lonely children who love to learn
embrace their education that's really
all there was to it and it appears she
was telling the truth so far the
foundation has found nothing that hints
at a nefarious motivation behind miss
jay's actions it would appear she truly
does just want to help children zenya
touched by the kindness that this safe
class anomaly showed her as a neglected
child and having now seen the positive
impact that she had on children like her
thanked miss j for all she'd done and
left the interview happy that there was
an scp out there who just wanted to
change people's lives for the better and
probably all of us would be a little
better off if there were more after all
this was one of the few scps who changed
a few good people's lives for the better
and all of us can probably learn
something from the kindness and patience
of miss jay and since you're already
here go check out
scp-3999 i in the center of everything
that happens to me and
scp-2317 the devourer of worlds a door
to another world for more mysterious
entities from the scp foundation